quedaros con la siguiente imagen porque
es una fotografía que a partir de ahora
va a aparecer siempre en los libros de
historia
lo sabéis en ella aparece teresa mail
primera ministra del reino unido-
firmando la carta que invoca el artículo
50 del tratado de lisboa y esta es la
carta con la que definitivamente se pone
en marcha el break sit
con esta carta amigos se pone en marcha
la separación entre el reino unido y la
unión europea así hace unos minutos en
bruselas el representante permanente de
reino unido ante la unión europea
entregó una carta al presidente del
consejo europeo en mi nombre confirmando
en la decisión del gobierno de invocar
el artículo 50 del tratado de la unión
europea la tramitación del artículo 50
está ahora en marcha y de acuerdo con
los deseos del pueblo británico el reino
unido deja la unión europea tridente de
york y en unión ya lo veis la ruptura es
un hecho ahora ya sólo queda negociar
sus condiciones y para hacerlo hay un
plazo de dos años te parece mucho pues
aunque pueda parecer pero lo cierto es
que van a ser unas negociaciones
realmente duras al fin y al cabo son
muchas las cosas que hay que acordar
para llevar a cabo la separación y
también muchos los intereses creados
podemos decir amigos de visual política
que las consecuencias van a ser enormes
y algunas ya han comenzado a tener
efectos ojo no sólo fuera de casa
también dentro el pasado 13 de marzo de
la primera ministra de escocia y
del partido nacional de escocia el
abanderado de la independencia nicolás
torresán anunció su intención de
convocar un referéndum de independencia
a finales de 2018 o principios de 2019
quince días más tarde el 28 de marzo el
parlamento de escocia le dio su apoyo
sí así es amigos escocia quiere hacer
añicos el matrimonio británico y
rememorando las hazañas de william
wallace su héroe nacional lograr la
libertad puede que los tristes la vida
pero jamás nos quitarán la libertad
bueno aunque a decir verdad no todos los
escoceses quieren la independencia hace
relativamente muy poco tiempo el 18 de
septiembre de 2014 ya hubo un primer
referéndum y los partidarios de la
independencia perdieron no fue por mucho
pero en aquella ocasión la unión
británica se salvó
[Música]
pues bien el break sheet ha causado un
nuevo giro en los acontecimientos y ha
vuelto a poner todo patas arriba porque
los escoceses apoyaron abrumadoramente
el remake la permanencia en la unión
europea así que será este nuevo
desencuentro el que finalmente termine
con más de 300 años de unión
el matrimonio británico la tierra de las
gaitas el whisky y el mítico monstruo
del lago ness escocia es una tierra de
verdes montañas frondosos bosques y
bellísimos castillos casi
fantasmagóricos que resisten indomables
el paso del tiempo
no
pues bien bañada por las bravas aguas
del gélido mar del norte escocia ha sido
para la historia moderna mucho más
importante de lo que tal vez os
imaginéis escocia ha sido por ejemplo la
tierra natal de adam smith el padre del
libre mercado de james watt el inventor
de la máquina de vapor clave para la
revolución industrial y también de som
connery con su caza del octubre rojo
cuando llegó el nuevo mundo cortez que
bolt sus naves de ese modo sus hombres
tuvieron una buena motivación
vamos que tal vez el capitalismo no
hubiese sido posible sin escocia cuando
menos no hubiese sido lo mismo el caso
es que en 1707 el viejo reino de escocia
y el reino de inglaterra acordaron unir
sus destinos y crear un parlamento y un
régimen único el reino de gran bretaña
al que más tarde se incorporó irlanda
creando el reino unido de gran bretaña e
irlanda hoy reinó unido- a secas de
hecho si os fijáis la unión jack es la
suma de la bandera de escocia de la
bandera de inglaterra y de la que
entonces era la bandera de irlanda
escocia ocupa un tercio de todo el
territorio pero tan sólo supone el 8 por
ciento de la población del reino unido a
pesar de ser tan pocos en los últimos
tiempos los escoceses han tenido una
presencia muy activa en la actualidad
del reino unido- y no sólo por el
movimiento independentista
gordon brown- por ejemplo el primer
ministro británico entre 2007 y 2010 es
escocés
[Música]
estoy convencido de que os estáis
preguntando por qué quieren los
escoceses romper 307 años de amor veamos
la ruptura
reino unido es un país bastante peculiar
respecto a la configuración de su mapa
territorial podemos decir que es un
estado formado por cuatro naciones
constitutivas y cada una de ellas tiene
sus particularidades
escocia gales e inglaterra e irlanda del
norte por ejemplo escocia ha tenido
tradicionalmente una identidad propia
muy acusada y muchas diferencias como un
sistema legal propio y también un
sistema educativo y uno religioso
diferentes a los de gales en la tierra
por ejemplo a pesar de ello aquí las
decisiones de verdad las decisiones de
peso siempre las ha tomado
londres que ha tenido la última palabra
en prácticamente cualquier cosa
esta situación comenzó a cambiar en 1997
cuando mediante referéndum se aprobó una
primera gran descentralización del poder
gracias a ello un año más tarde se creó
el parlamento de escocia que además
empezó a adquirir competencias en
materia de gasto como sanidad policía
educación etcétera
gracias a este parlamento territorial el
partido nacional escocés y el partido
que aboga por la independencia comenzó a
ganar más y más peso hoy es con mucha
diferencia la primera fuerza política de
escocia pero volvamos a la pregunta por
qué quieren tantos escoceses la
independencia pues en parte por lo que
estamos comentando hay una sensación
bastante generalizada de que escocia no
tiene prácticamente ninguna o al menos
muy poca influencia en londres y por si
eso fuese poco encima se da la
circunstancia de que entre escocia e
inglaterra hay muchas diferencias
políticas
[Música]
mientras inglaterra es una zona más de
centroderecha escocia es algo así como
un fortín de la socialdemocracia fijaros
mientras en el resto de europa
abundan los nacionalismos xenófobos y
racistas y el caso del partido nacional
de escocia es bastante diferente no
importa de dónde vengas lo que importa
es hacia dónde vamos como nación puede
ser paquistaní escocés polaco escocés o
incluso inglés escocés escocia aspira a
convertirse en algo así como la arcadia
de la socialdemocracia sin embargo como
políticamente tiene muy poquito peso a
pesar de no haber votado desde hace años
al centroderecha casi siempre están bajo
la dirección de un downing street-
girado a la derecha y eso es algo que
molesta mucho a los escoceses porque les
hace sentir que carecen de cualquier
soberanía además el sentimiento popular
pasa por que londres ha preocupado poco
muy poco por escocia y que incluso les
ha arrebatado los ingresos del petróleo
que se extrae en sus costas
y ojo no penséis que las diferencias son
solo respecto a qué partido político
votar o que se quedan sólo en el terreno
económico para nada para que os hagáis
una idea de las discrepancias llegan
incluso a las armas nucleares
los ingleses dicen sí y los escoceses
las rechazan mayoritariamente
pero visto esto tal vez sea oportuno
preguntarse bueno y si finalmente
llegamos al divorcio qué consecuencias
se pueden esperar
[Música]
el riesgo de divorcio y sus
consecuencias si finalmente se celebra
un segundo referéndum por la
independencia de escocia y esta vez gana
el sí qué consecuencias podemos esperar
pues bien por un lado para el resto del
reino unido- muy pocas prácticamente
ninguna tal vez algo desde el punto de
vista geoestratégico pero vamos nada del
otro mundo como decíamos antes escocia
representa una parte muy pequeña de la
población y una parte muy pequeña de la
economía
qué pasa por el otro lado qué
consecuencias tendría para escocia la
independencia bueno aquí el caso es un
poco diferente es verdad no hay duda de
que escocia podría perfectamente
convertirse en un país independiente de
hecho estaría entre los 20 más ricos del
mundo ahora bien puede que el escenario
no sea tan bonito como algunos pintan
en primer lugar las cosas han cambiado
mucho desde el anterior referéndum en
empezando por el precio del petróleo que
se ha desplomado
hoy esa joya ese cohete que muchos
pensaban que era el petróleo para la
economía escocesa ya no lo es
de hecho como es muy caro extraerlo del
mar del norte para lo que hay que
utilizar plataformas como esta que vemos
las compañías apenas ganan dinero y el
estado no ve una libra
además claro como las compañías no ganan
dinero tampoco invierten y cierran
aquellas instalaciones que pierden
dinero el resultado muchos despidos y
una economía que crece mucho menos que
la del resto del país segundo y muy
ligado a lo primero el paraíso
socialdemócrata hay que pagarlo y si el
petróleo no va bueno escocia tiene un
déficit fiscal de casi el 10 por ciento
que hoy puede soportar gracias a las
subvenciones al dinero que le entrega a
londres
[Música]
tercero el break sheet lo ha cambiado
todo me explico escocia vende a
inglaterra cuatro veces más que a toda
la unión europea así que si se
independiza para volver a entrar en el
grupo europeo el resultado podría ser
muy malo para sus empresas y negocios
imaginaros que para ganar el 25% del
mercado pierden el 75% vamos que el
break 7 es rechazado por los escoceses
pero puede que al mismo tiempo sea el
mejor instrumento para que el matrimonio
continúe al menos unos cuantos años más
pero como siempre la única certeza
amigos sólo nos la puede dar el paso del
tiempo lo que ya está claro es que el
break sheet ya ha comenzado reino unido
será el primer país en romper y
abandonar la unión europea aquí en
visual político le hemos dedicado ya
unos cuantos vídeos este tema por
ejemplo si queréis conocer como los
británicos esperan superar su ruptura
con la unión europea no os perdáis este
vídeo donde os lo contamos con todo
detalle pero volviendo al tema de este
vídeo tú qué crees veremos pronto un
nuevo país independiente llamado escocia
conseguir a este pequeño país superar la
crisis en la que está envuelto que crees
que sería mejor para los escoceses
quedarse omar
el reino unido esperamos tus opiniones
como siempre nos las puedes dejar en los
comentarios por supuesto si te ha
gustado el vídeo no olvides darle a like
y suscribirte también al canal un saludo
y hasta la próxima